[Music]
as i review the events of my past life
i realize how subtle are the influences
that shape our destinies
an incident of my youth may serve to
illustrate
one winter's day i managed to climb a
steep mountain
in company with other boys the snow was
quite deep and a warm
southerly wind made it just suitable for
the purpose
we mused ourselves by throwing balls
which would roll down a certain distance
gathering more or less snow and we tried
to outdo one another in this exciting
sport
suddenly a ball was seen to go beyond
the limit
swelling to enormous proportions until
it became as big as a house
and plunged thundering into the valley
below with a force that made the ground
tremble i looked on spellbound
incapable of understanding what had
happened for weeks afterward the picture
of the avalanche was before my eyes
and i wondered how anything so small
could grow
to such an immense size ever since that
time
the magnification of feeble actions
fascinated me
and when years later i took up the
experimental study of mechanical
and electrical resonance i was keenly
interested
from the very start possibly had it not
been for that early powerful impression
i might not have followed up the little
spark i obtained with my coil
and never developed my best invention
i was offered a position in paris which
i gladly accepted
[Music]
i can never forget the deep impression
that magic city produced on my mind
for several days after my arrival i
roamed through the streets and utter
bewilderment of the new spectacle
the attractions were many and
irresistible i had a rather
strenuous life in what would now be
termed rooseveltian fashion
every morning regardless of weather i
would go from the boulevard saint marcel
where i resided
to a bathing house on the sen plunge
into the water
loop the circuit 27 times and then walk
an hour to reach evri
where the company's factory was located
there i would have a wood choppers
breakfast at half past seven o'clock
and then eagerly await the lunch hour in
the meanwhile cracking hard nuts for the
manager of the works
mr charles batchelor who was an intimate
friend and assistant
of edison here i was thrown in contact
with a few americans
who fairly fell in love with me because
of my proficiency in billiards
the utter failure of my attempts to
raise capital for development
was another disappointment and when mr
bachelor pressed me to go to america
with a view of redesigning the edison
machines i was determined
to try my fortunes in the land of golden
[Music]
promise
this video was sponsored by private
internet access a great value
reliable vpn service here at voices of
the past a lot of our videos explore
international perspectives and
incredible journeys to fire off lands to
try and understand how foreign cultures
live and think and that is what a vpn
can do when it comes to netflix and all
your favorite streaming services
if nikola tesla had used private
internet access he would have had no
trouble
accessing all the geo-restricted content
from back home in serbia
indeed i'm based in spain and private
internet access has meant that i can
even access
japanese television because it may come
as a surprise to you guys
but i like japan on top of this the
encryption services and
000 servers in 70 countries makes
private internet access a great choice
when going online safely so click on the
link in the description to get complete
digital privacy
for less than three dollars a month and
three extra months
for free thanks for your time and back
to the journey
i liquefied my modest assets secured
accommodations and found myself at the
railroad station
as the train was pulling out at that
moment i discovered that my money
and tickets were gone what to do was the
question
hercules had plenty of time to
deliberate but i had to decide while
running alongside the train
with opposite feelings surging in my
brain like condenser oscillations
resolve helped by dexterity won out in
the nick of time
and upon passing through the usual
experiences i managed to embark
for new york with the remnants of my
belongings some poems and articles i had
written
and a packet of calculations related to
solutions of an unsolvable integral
and to my flying machine
i wish that i could put in words my
first impression of this country
in the arabian tales i read how gene i
transported people into a land of dreams
to live through
delightful adventures my case was just
the reverse
the gene eye had carried me from a world
of dreams
into one of realities what i had left
was beautiful
artistic and fascinating in every way
what i saw here
was machined rough and unattractive
a burly policeman was twirling his stick
which looked to me as big as a log
i approached him politely with the
request to direct me
six blocks down then to the left he said
with murder in his eyes
is this america i asked myself in
painful surprise
it is a century behind europe in
civilization
and yet when i went abroad in 1889
five years having elapsed since my
arrival here i became convinced
that it was more than 100 years ahead of
europe
and nothing has happened to this day to
change my opinion
the meeting with edison was a memorable
event in my life
i was amazed at this wonderful man who
without early advantages in scientific
training
had accomplished so much i had studied a
dozen languages
delved in literature and art and had
spent my best years in
libraries reading all sorts of stuff
that fell into my hands
from newton's principia to the novels of
paul de [ __ ]
and felt that most of my life had been
squandered
but it did not take long before i
recognized that it was the best
thing i could have done within a few
weeks i had won
edison's confidence and it came about
in this way
[Music]
the ss oregon the fastest passenger
steamer at that time
had both of its lighting machines
disabled and its sailing was delayed
as the superstructure had been built
after their installation
it was impossible to remove them from
the hold the predicament was a serious
one
and edison was much annoyed in the
evening i took the necessary instruments
with me
and went aboard the vessel where i
stayed for the night
[Music]
the dynamos were in bad condition having
several short circuits and breaks
but with the assistance of the crew i
succeeded in putting them in good shape
at five o'clock in the morning when
passing along fifth avenue on my way to
the shop
i met edison with bachelor and a few
others as they were returning home to
retire
here is our parisian running around at
night he said
when i told him that i was coming from
the oregon and had repaired both
machines
he looked at me in silence and walked
away without another word
but when he had gone some distance i
heard him remark
bachelor this is a damn good man
and from that time on i had full freedom
in directing the work
for nearly a year my regular hours were
from 10 30 a.m
until five o'clock the next morning
without a day's exception
edison said to me i have had many
hard-working assistants
but you take the cake during this period
i designed
24 different types of standard machines
with short cores and of uniform pattern
which replaced the old ones the manager
had promised me fifty thousand dollars
on the completion of this task
but it turned out to be a practical joke
this gave me a painful shock
and i resigned my position
[Music]
immediately thereafter some people
approached me with the proposal of
forming an arc-like
company under my name to which i agreed
here finally was an opportunity to
develop the motor
but when i broached the subject to my
new associates they said
no we want the ark lamp we don't care
for this
alternating current of yours
in 1886 my system of arc lighting was
perfected and adopted for factory and
municipal lighting
and i was free but with no other
possession than a beautifully engraved
certificate of stock of hypothetical
value
then followed a period of struggle in
the new medium for which i was not
fitted
but the reward came in the end and in
april 1887
the tesla electric company was organized
providing a laboratory
and facilities the motors i built there
were exactly as i'd imagined them
i made no attempt to improve the design
but nearly reproduced the pictures as
they appeared to my vision
and the operation was always as i
expected
in the early part of 1888 an arrangement
was made with the westinghouse company
for the manufacture of the motors on a
large scale
but great difficulties still had to be
overcome they did not want to depart
from their standard forms of apparatus
and my efforts had to be concentrated
upon adapting the motor
to these conditions another necessity
was to produce a motor capable of
running efficiently at this frequency
on two wires which was not easy to
accomplish
at the close of 1889 however my services
in pittsburgh being no longer essential
i returned to new york and resumed
experimental work in a laboratory on
grand street
where i began immediately the design of
high frequency machines
the problems of construction in this
unexplored field were novel
and quite peculiar and i encountered
many difficulties
despite this my progress was so rapid as
to enable me to exhibit at my lectures
in 1891
a coil giving sparks of five inches
since my early announcement of the
invention it has come into universal use
and wrought a revolution in many
departments
but a still greater future awaits it
when in 1900 i obtained powerful
discharges of 100 feet and flashed a
current around the globe
i was reminded of the first tiny spark i
observed
in my grand street laboratory and was
thrilled by sensations akin to those i
felt
when i discovered the rotating magnetic
field
in one of these biographical sketches i
have dwelt on the circumstances of my
early life and told of an affliction
which compelled me to unremitting
exercise of imagination and
self-observation
this mental activity at first
involuntary under the pressure of
illness and suffering
gradually became second nature and led
me finally to realize that i was but
an automaton devoid of free will in
thought
and action and merely responsive to the
forces
of the environment our bodies are of
such complexity of structure
the motions we perform are so numerous
and involved
and the external impressions on our
sense organs to such a degree
delicate and elusive that it is hard
for the average person to grasp this
fact
we are automata entirely controlled by
the forces of the medium
being tossed about like corks on the
surface of the water
but mistaking the resultant of the
impulses from the outside
for free will the movements and other
actions we perform
are always life preservative and though
seemingly quite independent from one
another
we are connected by invisible links
a very sensitive and observant being
with his
highly developed mechanism all intact
and acting with precision
in obedience to the changing conditions
of the environment
is endowed with a transcending
mechanical sense
enabling him to evade perils too subtle
to be directly perceived
[Music]
you